alors vous vous dites jean frédéric
poisson on ne se confine rap à vous
appeler les gens à ne pas se recombiner
qu'est ce que vous en pensez tient chez
vous et qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ici alors vous est ce que vous comprenez
les français qui refusent de se
recombiner et vous vous en faites partie
le ce gouvernement est désespérant il
est incapable de gérer cette crise
sanitaire
l'exaspération la rage des français sont
sont palpables en même temps qu'une
espèce de désespoir de désemparement et
je les comprends parce que en dehors de
tout ce qu'on peut dire sur les chiffres
des qui existant bien entendu même s'il
y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire sur
la réalité de ces chiffres là de malades
de contaminer et ses terrains moi ce que
je vois
avant tout c'est ces jeunes étudiants
qui finissent par devenir complètement
maboul parce que ils passent la journée
chez eux ces commerçants qui vont
refermer et qui pour beaucoup d'entre
eux ne reparaîtront pas parce que leur
commerce va disparaître toutes ces
entreprises qui vont mourir tous ces
gens qui sont en télétravail qui
finissent par péter mais pendant qu'au
fond ce confinement ne sert pas à grand
chose à la désobéissance
oui oui mais un petit un petit exemple
que je prend rapidement on a entendu
parler de ces trois tgv médicalisé qui
aurait dû rouler et cette semaine ils ne
sont pas partis pourquoi parce qu'il y
avait pas assez de monde à mettre dedans
et la raison c'est que les familles ont
refusé de voir les membres de leur
famille qui pouvait être emmenés dans
des hôpitaux en province ils ont refusé
cet éloignement et je me dis voilà ces
actes là qui sont des contestation
pacifique
normal elles sont juste sur le plan
éthique sont des résistances à la
politique du gouvernement et je trouve
ça très bien et pourvu que ça continue
mais j'ai vers l'avant ou tomber des
nues l'action j'ai le temps de dénicher
alors je rappelle six ans frédéric
poisson frais président la voix du
président de la boad et porte donc
candidat à la présidentielle 2022 alors
messieurs en responsabilité ce que vous
dites est non seulement démagogique mais
c'est dangereux vous appelle à la
désobéissance civile vous appelez à
l'illégalité mais soit la souffrance et
elle est réelle réel est partagé par
tout le monde soit à ce moment là il n'y
a plus d'esprit collectif c'est l'ère de
l'individualisme et la république
française dont vous devriez partager les
valeurs c'est que on obéit à la loi on
obéit au gouvernement s'il n'ya plus de
règles monsieur je suis effaré par vos
propos alors benjamin castaldi aussi par
exemple bien sûr évidemment et puis
surtout honnêtement la matin on n'est
plus à faire
ce courrier est à chaque fois qu'un
politique sur ce plateau ce qui moi ce
qui me rend fou c'est que à chaque fois
vous ramener ce combi en faisant une
campagne et ça franchement je vous le
dis ça devrait exercer d insulte
insupportable que soit vous les 7 jours
de tiaré couverture explique que vous
voyez on refait le match alors il
reparle des masques oui effectivement il
ya eu plein de plein de gars qui ont
comme quoi tous vécu mais aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce que vous
proposez
comme d'habitude à rien donc maintenant
il va voler pour se serre les coudes
tous ensemble qu'on arrête de faire de
la polémique de tirer la couverture
décès de gratter des voix à gauche ou à
droite ou aux extrêmes et moi
franchement aujourd'hui on doit être
ensemble et pas à dire ah ben non
fallait pas voir s'il fallait pas
proposer autre chose je fais mon boulot
ces principes je suis pas venu en
forçant la porte non on a appris hier
deuxièmement vous m'invitez parce que je
suis un responsable politique est donc
bien sûr en 11e manche en low carbon
troisièmement je suis désolé de vous
dire que il ya tellement d'incohérences
temps de gestion de cette crise
sanitaire c'est ça que je voudrais
pointé aussi
deuxièmement il ya tellement
d'impossibilité de débattre sur le fond
en vérité sur la vérité de la situation
il ya plein d'éléments j'ai pas d'après
le fonds le vif on le fond de quoi le
bal ne faille du fond c'est quoi le fond
la vérité croix expliqué nous tailler
dans le fond de quoi ah mais si la
vérité sur la stratégie vaccinale c'est
la vérité sur les chiffres de
réanimation c'est on est en train de
faire croire aux français que le
confinement est inéluctable alors je
vous somme ce n'est pas ce que nous
disaient leur maître g b 0-2 pension
savez sauverait jean frédéric poisson et
le droit de considérer qu'il ya d'autres
solutions
jean-frédéric il voit sur fallu faire
autrement qu'il n'est pas trop tard pour
faire autour du cou on alors ce que vous
pensez être j'en ferais jean frédéric
poisson oui juste c'est ce que nous
disait hier m e division m division hier
sur ce plateau il a même quitté le
plateau hier parce qu'il dit que mon
beauf les chiffres sur de la réanimation
mais je vois pas la télé alors justement
je me tourne vers laurent alexandre
chirurgien et essayiste est ce que cette
théorie est plausible noms et les
complotistes d'accord il est délirant
d'imaginer que les médecins m en
réanimation des malades qui ne doivent
pas y être
quand on sait à quel point c'est
désastreux d'être en réanimation
on souffre énormément en réanimation
c'est un endroit très très difficile on
est en réanimation que des malades
extrêmement sévère donc prétendre que
nous médecins exprès pour emmerder le
gouvernement omet des malades qui ne
devrait pas être en réanimation en
réanimation sur ceux de ses délires
comme ces insultante et hors média
finalement scandaleux donc il ya un
moment où il faut arrêter ces propos
délirants
jamais un médecin ne ferait souffrir un
malade en le mettant à tort en
réanimation ce sont des propos
diffamatoires et scandales qui ont été
tenus alors juste quand vous entendez
donc que c'est bon on manipule les
chiffres voilà que les chiffres sont
fous des animations c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi et quand on est
médecin et qu'on a fait de la réa et
qu'on a vu jusqu'à une réa
on n'imagine pas une seconde qu'on
puisse mettre exprès en réanimation un
malade qui ne méritent pas d'y être
parce que la réa c'est vraiment très
très c'est nécessaire pour les malades
qui sont graves mais c'est un endroit où
on souffre beaucoup quand on est malade
et on y met que les malades qui est
vraiment nécessite une réanimation
personne ne dise à dr et certainement
pas moi je serai bientôt une version
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit alger sur les
chiffres je dis simplement que je
constate qu' il ya beaucoup d'hôpitaux
privés dans lesquels des lits sont
disponibles on les utilise pas pourquoi
il y à des hôpitaux des services de
réanimation à l'hôtel-dieu par exemple
ont été démantelés ya peu de temps dont
les équipements sont encore parfait de
vente actifs et utilisa personne ne les
utilisent pour quoi et si donc il y a
dans beaucoup d'endroits en france des
hôpitaux des centres hospitaliers qui
pourrait accueillir des malades en aval
la réanimation par exemple puisque
malheureusement quand il ya assez peu de
lui-même ce qui pourrait avoir des
traitements un peu plus légers restent
dans les services devrait aujourd'hui
parce qu'apple place on pourrait
d'étendre ses services
et lorsque j'entends et je comprends
comme nous tous au fond c'est à cause de
cette tension sur des services de
réanimation conre confine sûr il ya des
moyens de détendre ça en amont avec des
traitements en aval avec de la
répartition alors sur les services qui
sont inoccupés comprenez vous les ferons
si le confinement c'est à cause de ça
pardonnez moi c'est une très mauvaise
décision et paul il a entamé ce cher
pour miranda bien compris le rang